Colin first of all welcome to St Louis
welcome to the St Louis chess club and
the American copy you opened the show
for us how was uh that experience for
you I was very fun ring ring the bell uh
starting the game you came from
California it was a long trip for you
who is your favorite player here uh the
same with just like we're hearing that
you're a big chess fan yeah probably
Hikaru just because I like watching his
streams uh but I played a game against
LeBron and he was really nice so that
was fun did you get to interact with any
of the players I saw that you were
chatting with Lanier Dominguez talking
with a couple before the game yeah tell
us a bit about your style you play a lot
as well are you more of a tactical
player more of a strategical player how
would you describe it
definitely
uh
uh tactical player yeah
I'm I'm not I'm not the best
but I try
absolutely guys any questions for uh
Colin yeah I have a question yeah I just
want to know what is your favorite
opening call
oh okay any nice tricks that you've
learned
um
any tricks in the real Lopez
not not really and what's your favorite
owning with the black pieces let's say I
open up with one D4 what would you do
after that uh I usually play the England
Gambit against that
E4 I play
um that's a streamer's opening what
that's a streamer's opening a YouTube
twitch all of those things it's a fun
opening to play a lot of uh a lot of
tactical nuances right yeah yeah sir
yeah I think you were you about to say
college you play the karaoke
were you about to say that you played
the Karo Khan yeah I can see foreign
[Music]
man after my own heart well well well
done
um who's your favorite in the uh you
said Hikaru uh in this American Cup
in the American Cup who's your favorite
player let's say outside of Chicago who
do you expect to win you like it who do
you expect to win expect to win
um
I want to say Fabiano he's
he's just he's really good they're all
really good though uh Wesley sews also
one of the top ones in the tournament
and did you manage to see to catch some
uh some of the moments from yesterday's
match between Wesley and Fabi
uh yeah yeah it was uh
very interesting I was watching most of
the games on the on YouTube yeah yeah
that was uh that was definitely a fun
match guys any more questions yeah just
one I I I've just got to ask it uh you
honor as Colin by in your make a wish
wish uh to be here in St Louis and to be
uh in the Chess World you could have
chosen anything in the world you're
gonna run back a NFL uh touchdown if you
had wanted but this is this was your
wish why
uh I've always been really interesting
really interested in chess uh and
watching all the professional games I
just like to see how the best people
play
and
I mean
I've been to Hawaii
so yeah yeah so you might as well come
St Louis
I love it I love it Colin before uh we
let you go we do have a gift from the
Saint Louis chess club we have the
American jacket American Cup jacket for
you this is reserved only for the
players it's not up for sale but you get
one that's so much lovely uh bring the
jacket with you for dinner tonight and
we'll get all the players to sign the
sleeves oh nice yeah that's what I'm
talking that is really really nice we'll
see you later at the dinner tonight
Colin thank you absolutely thank you
Colin wow yeah make a wish make a wish a
big big big thanks to that Foundation
because of all of the great things that
they do uh this is very special it's
it's wonderful it is wonderful and uh
you know just to give Hope just to give
laughter smiles to everyone actually
because it's such a beautiful thing you
know exactly yeah Colin wanted to play a
chess and who wants to see the best
players in America coincidentally the
world